for more than 25 years there's been a
medieval castle under construction in
France the builders and designers here
are using plans and techniques that are
as historically accurate to the 13th
century as possible get along Castle is
experimental archeology and a tourist
attraction the techniques rediscovered
here they're now helping with the
Reconstruction of Notre Dame cathedral
but I'm here for one very specific piece
of technology that I'd never heard of
and which to me feels like something out
of the anachronistic fiction of
asterisks or The Flintstones it's called
the treadmill Crane and it is a real
thing from history now I'm not an
archaeologist or a historian so I'm
going to let someone tell you about this
place and about this crane while I
actually go and get some Stone and learn
to power this thing so when we say we're
building a medieval castle of course we
have to be very clear about which period
of the Middle Ages we're interested in
so we've narrowed down our area of
interest to the 13th century to be even
more precise when we laid the first
stone we said it was the year 1228 and
each year we move forward in history so
this here on site you are in the year of
Our Lord 1253 so in order to find out
what technology was available at that
time we have a number of different
sources we use illuminated manuscripts
stained glass windows Financial records
of course we work with archaeologists
art historians and castillologists and
so we put all that information together
in order to decide how the castle should
be built sometimes we know how to do it
sometimes these skills have never been
lost others have been completely lost
and we have to then revive them from
scratch the
itself will be finished in about another
10 years so we're taking about 35 years
in order to finish the castle which is a
really long time compared to the Middle
Ages because one of the reasons that
we're building this Castle is to show
the visiting public so half the time my
colleagues are putting down their Tools
in order to explain the work we're doing
so here we are at the single drum winch
so so that needs to go up there yes we
can provide the Tower with those rocks
so we can build it okay we might say
that we're building a 13th century
Castle but in terms of health and safety
we're clearly in the 21st century so you
will see anachronisms on site we have
hard hats steel toe cap shoes protective
eyewear masks when we're working with
the Sandstone from the Quarry all this
scaffolding is heavily reinforced so
obviously we're not trying to discover
how many people were killed or injured
in the 13th century so take care of your
back the council that we're building
here today is the castle that would have
belonged to a low ranking local fairly a
modest nobleman this isn't a royal
castle it's essentially being built as a
private home but there will be defensive
elements within the castle there'll be a
portcullis there'll be murder holes
Arrow Loops crenellated Walling and all
of this even though there's very little
chance that the castle would have been
attacked in the middle of the 13th
century these features are still in
place you never know there's not any
fancy modern pulleys or anything like
that it's just no it's just diameter of
this versus diameter of this yes it's
like if you were making an effort of
five flight of stairs so if you are
walking 10 meter is one meter up it's
like a giant gear basically so we have a
couple of single drumed cranes and we
also have a double drummed tread wheel
winch and the advantage of that
particular piece of Machinery is it it
pivots through 360 degrees so that
allows us to hoist loads up from the
Quarry and then spin the Machinery
around and place it exactly where we
need it on the masonry with the double
drum winch we can hoist somewhere in the
region of 500 kilos that's a thousand
pounds in weight with the single drum
winch where there's one person working
so it's half 250 kilos roughly so I'm
going to lift 200 kilos with this one
all right 150 200s okay safety is
obviously Paramount when we're using
this Machinery so we have someone who's
responsible for applying the brakes it
means that there's no danger of someone
spinning around like in a washing
machine we have someone who's at the
base responsible for charging the cradle
and then one person who is in charge of
the whole operation keeping an eye on
how far the Walkers still have to walk
because of course when you're in the
machine you can't necessarily see so
it's a very carefully managed process
this is a technology that goes back to
Roman times but which is being used in
the 13th century in Cathedral
construction we know that they were in
use because there are a number of
medieval cranes that still exist in the
roof Timbers of cathedrals Canterbury
Cathedral for example has a wonderful
example of that are you going to be on
the break does it have a break look
this is no more break you can see here
yep it's just friction on that that yeah
there's no evidence of a braking system
on these medieval cranes for safety
reasons we've included one so that we
can stop it if necessary
strictly speaking if all's while you
just stop walking okay okay just go
ahead and get your head all right
and right now this won't move because
you're on the brake so you can look at
fixed points to help you yeah because if
I'm looking at this yeah it will be
Disneyland yep are you ready ready okay
just walk walk oh oh wow
hahaha and look to the side if I look
ahead
it gets really confusing gotta look that
way yeah gotta look that way
hey but it's working yeah it's working
oh you're right about that fixed Point
yes I look forward for a bit and started
getting dizzy
I'm just walking up a steep hill
there is some kind of feedback loop the
faster I walk the faster it turns the
faster it pushes me back because of
course I'm moving more but then I risk
bashing my head into the axle behind me
in case you're wondering yeah it's just
quite tiring
so these machines are absolutely
necessary in the construction process we
couldn't build the castle at the rate we
are without them we hoist somewhere in
the region of three metric tons every
day there we go
okay okay
and stop
congratulations
for your first medieval cream thank you
I didn't expect quite the tourist the
tourist Applause though thank you very
much always